These [music] are the chips powering a
transformational technology reshaping
how we live, work, and communicate.
>> [music]
>> They sit at the heart of a new race
between Washington and Beijing. The
outcome will help determine each
superpower's status in a changing world.
And right now, the most advanced
semiconductors are designed by US
companies.
>> They are also highly sought after by
China.
>> The chips that go into training and and
running models are the most complicated
[music]
things that humans make. These are maybe
the most valuable goods in the world.
>> And US export controls are meant to
prevent their sale to China, but a
thriving market for smuggled silicon has
emerged. The stakes are enormous. China
cares [music] both from a technology
point of view, a business point of view,
and a political point of view.
>> We're going to show you how this illegal
trade works. [music] This guy is
claiming that he's just taken stock of a
big load of H200s that's come through
Hong Kong and it's going to be delivered
to [music] Shenzhen.
>> We will also reveal how the controls are
tearing Chinese and US technology
companies apart.
>> And forcing Chinese chip makers to
innovate. It is also opened a new sphere
of competition between the two
superpowers.
>> But first, let's explain what export
controls are and why they're being used
by Washington.
>> [music]
>> Why is China so desperate to acquire US
designated chips?
The reason is obvious.
AI is truly transformative technology
and it's already changing how we fight
wars, run our government, and operate
companies.
It's essential for the United States to
maintain a decisive lead in the AI race.
>> In 2022,
the US government introduced blanket
bans on the sale of the most advanced
chips to China.
>> These chips were invented in America.
Let's get that straight. They're
invented in America.
>> [applause]
>> We used to make 40% of the world's
chips.
>> [music]
>> Export controls were born in the
aftermath of the Second World War when
the world was divided along ideological
lines.
The US [music] and its allies on one
side, the Soviet Union on the other.
Both sides were locked in a Cold War and
a nuclear arms race.
Washington knew that technological
supremacy would ensure military
dominance. So in 1949, it created rules
to stop Moscow from obtaining critical
Western technology.
>> [cheering]
>> But the fall of the Berlin Wall and the
dawn of the 21st century created a new
strategic rivalry, this time between the
US and a rising China.
Many in Washington see Beijing as a
threat to the US-led world order.
And China's AI development is something
that must be curtailed. It has turned to
this Cold War era rulebook to stop its
new rival.
>> [music]
>> Kevin Cohlins spent 28 years at the
Department of Commerce. [music]
>> Most advanced chips and certainly AI
chips that are designed by US companies
and many Western companies are virtually
all fabbed or produced in in Taiwan
usually at TSMC and then those products
either get packaged in Taiwan or in
third countries and then from the
packagers they're directed then to
either send the items back to the
designer or many times they're just
directly sent to an integrator if you
will or a distribution chain. And so
in order to harden these supply chains,
you really need to have an export
compliance program that not only
addresses the activities that are
happening for example
in the United States, but their
distribution networks and who their
customers are.
>> [music]
>> In this tech war between China and the
US, [music] Taiwan plays a critical
role.
The island has emerged as an essential
node in the global semiconductor supply
chain.
That Beijing wants to reunify with
Taiwan has only added to the
geopolitical significance of this story.
I've witnessed Taiwan's growth [music]
into an AI powerhouse first as a student
and later as a reporter.
I've returned to Taipei [music] to
attend Computex, the world's most
important chip conference.
What is on display here today is the
most leading edge AI products, which are
not allowed for export in China. These
AI chips have become more and more
powerful,
more and more capable of training
bigger, more powerful AI models and the
American government has stopped Chinese
companies from getting their hands on
these chips.
So this is one of the racks that go into
the large data center product. It's full
of Nvidia GPUs that are essential for
model training and inference, i.e., the
process of running AI models. And these
chips are among the series that are
restricted for shipment to China.
>> Chris McGuire has advised both the Biden
and Trump administrations on China and
emerging technologies.
>> Computing power is the core input into
AI. It is the reason that training and
developing these models is the most
expensive thing that humans are doing
right now. But, Nvidia is just the
example frequently because they are so
significant. They are somewhere between
80 to 90% of the AI chip market. The
reason for that is that their products
are extremely good. They're very, very
good chips. They're very, very powerful.
Uh Nvidia has very, very robust supply
chains where they can ensure they can
really kind of maximize their output and
ensure delivery on time to customers as
well as they can given supply
constraints that they have.
>> The world's most valuable company is now
at the heart of geopolitics.
>> The United States is ahead in the AI
race and we have to stay ahead in the AI
race. So, we've taken China out of our
forecast. We're currently uh shipping
$0. Our market share has gone from 95%
to zero. We're currently assuming
China's going to be 0% of our business.
>> But, winning the AI race has become a
priority for Beijing.
President Xi Jinping is marshaling both
the state and private sectors to catch
up with the US.
>> The Chinese Ministry of State Security
has recently said that circumventing the
the US technology blockade is one of its
top priorities. It's certain that there
are kind of diversion campaigns that are
being facilitated by, you know, the
Chinese intelligence services in order
to support their technology companies.
This also is not surprising. This is a
This is an asset that they absolutely
need to stay competitive that they
cannot make themselves. And the only way
that they can actually remain
competitive is by either convincing the
United States to give it to them,
smuggling it, or exploiting loopholes in
the export controls that allow them to
continue to have access to them. Without
those things, there would be a very
significant drop-off for Chinese AI
capabilities, and I think the Chinese
government recognizes that and is
pulling out all the stops in order to
prevent that from happening.
>> Shares of Supermicro
computer are losing about 1/3 of their
value. It's because of an international
smuggling scandal.
>> In March this year, the US Department of
Justice targeted employees at
Supermicro, a Taiwanese company and
Nvidia partner. They stand accused of
smuggling 2.5 billion dollars worth of
Nvidia chips and servers into China.
The US alleges that a front company was
used to divert the chips. Supermicro was
not named as a defendant in the
indictment and has denied any
wrongdoing, as have [music] the named
defendants.
Still, analysts say that the case
highlights historic failings of the
export control regime.
>> The smuggling really ranges from kind of
mom-and-pop smuggling operations to very
large systematic kind of criminal
organizations.
Nvidia makes somewhere between 5 and 10
million of these chips per year. [music]
If there's three or four that go out the
back back, obviously you want to stop
that. But if you have organizations that
are funneling tens of thousands of
chips, that's a significant problem. And
I think that we've seen organizations
are committing that because this is an
extremely valuable industry.
>> So, I've been reporting on the various
tactics Chinese companies have used to
get their hands
American AI chips for about 4 years now.
It's been an evolving story, and these
companies have been using ever more
creative loopholes, some legal, some
illegal.
Last year we published an investigation
that provided a snapshot into how these
large-scale chip smuggling [music]
operations work. We found a paper trail
of contracts and had discussions with
middlemen and found evidence of at least
$1 billion of video GPUs being brought
into China.
The estimated number of of chips sold
here on the black market is far higher
than that, but really this story
provided an insight into how the
larger-scale operation works.
So, I'm on Xiaohongshu here, which is a
Chinese social media platform, and
[music] if you type in Nvidia or AMD,
you'll come up with a lot of these kinds
of posts by middlemen selling these
smuggled chips. Here we have H200s.
There's also someone selling B300s,
[music] which is a more advanced Nvidia
series. And if you go onto their
profiles, these guys are very clearly
advertising their [music] sales. This
guy is claiming that he's just taken
stock of a big load [music] of H200s
that's come through Hong Kong and it's
going to be delivered to Shenzhen.
Shenzhen is important for the chip
smuggling story for a variety of
different reasons. The first [music] of
which is it's a port city. It's close to
Hong Kong, which is a thoroughfare for a
lot of these smuggled chips. It is also
a place where there's a lot of AI
hardware, so server builders, rack
builders. It's somewhere where the chips
are just being sold and repackaged to
the rest of China. There are a lot of
tech salesmen based in Shenzhen. It's a
hardware hub in China. And so if you've
got requirements for new computers, new
servers, you go down to Shenzhen, you
speak to these middlemen, and they will
kind of create you a custom solution.
>> We are here at Huaqiangbei in Shenzhen,
a famous electronics market. You can
find any electronics component here,
including lots of people selling
second-hand chips. So we're going to go
and see if we can find anyone selling
Nvidia GPUs in here today.
>> The market is a labyrinth of retailers
selling all kinds of consumer [music]
electronics and the components that go
into them. I'm here to talk with a chip
reseller. She's agreed to be
interviewed, but not on camera given the
sensitivity of the topic.
>> Until recently, [music] it was also
possible to buy smuggled AI chips from
Nvidia and AMD, but in recent months,
it's become incredibly difficult to get
access to these because the Chinese
authorities have restricted imports of
these chips in order to support local
competitors. That means that the prices
of these have gone absolutely crazy.
We've spoken to a number of sellers in
this building and they said that prices
have gone absolutely crazy, exacerbated
also by the memory chip shortage. But,
for example, one
seller said that one B300 machine, that
is one of the leading server machines,
has almost doubled in price in recent
months.
Chinese companies are also exploiting
loopholes in the US export controls by
remotely accessing [music]
restricted chips.
>> Right now, the administration has not
articulated a coherent strategy for
controlling advanced compute and AI
chips. The most advanced Nvidia chips,
say a Blackwell that is located in a in
a data center in Malaysia, there's no
restriction on any Chinese company from
accessing the compute power on that
item. So, there's an inconsistency
there. There's also a loophole in the
current regulations that do not restrict
a Chinese front company in a third
country or a Chinese-owned data center
in a third country from buying the same
chips or servers that are restricted for
sale directly to China.
>> [music]
>> So, on the one hand, you have the
Chinese AI labs who want to build the
best models and it just so happens that
building the best model means access to
Nvidia GPUs. But, on the other hand, you
also have Chinese tech companies that
are trying to support the growth of
domestic AI chips, like Huawei and
Cambricon. And their argument is that we
should be supporting the growth of these
domestic chips. And if that means
relinquishing some progress or lead on
AI in the short term, that's okay. We
should be doing it for the long-term
goal of Chinese AI independence.
>> I don't buy that export controls have
driving China to self-sufficiency. They
had already put out a policy to do that.
To me, again, export controls are meant
to maintain US leadership by delaying
their ability to achieve the same goals
or or levels of innovation
that allow the United States to continue
to be a leader both from an economic and
a national security perspective.
>> The question is ultimately will China be
able to reach a level where Huawei or
one of the other Chinese AI companies is
equally or even better than the American
companies. And I think that's still a
massive open question. It looks like a
no for now, but you know, China has
proven time and time again that it's
very capable of building cutting-edge
technology.
>> Right now, the US leads by about 8
months in AI. That's per the latest US
government estimate. [music] What it
also means is AI is doubling in
capability about every 4 months. So, an
8-month lead means about a 4x capability
difference. That's significant, but it's
also not so significant that I think the
Chinese say, "Okay, well, we're down and
out." Right? They're They're looking at
this like we have an opportunity to
catch up. We're behind, but we think
[music] we can close the gap.
>> We certainly have become obsessed with
this idea of a time lag between the US
and China. [music] To me, I don't think
it matters a huge amount right now. What
certainly does matter is whether or not,
you know, the US is the first to build
this fated future of super general
intelligence. And [music] if and when we
get to that stage, it certainly looks
like America's going to be the first to
get there given the trajectory of the
model development at the moment.
>> The United States just needs to
recognize that the US and Chinese AI
ecosystems are fundamentally diverging.
That is exactly how it was in the Cold
War. The US and Soviet nuclear programs
in no way helped each other. They were
completely separate, uh and that is
undoubtedly in the national security
interest of the United States. That also
did not preclude cooperation between the
United States and the Soviet Union on
certain discrete areas where we had
shared interest. And I think in AI, we
probably need to think about cooperation
with China more in that sense.
>> For now, the US dominance in AI hardware
is clear. There are several chokeholds
that Chinese companies have not yet
broken.
It will take time and a lot of money to
build a rival ecosystem to the one
Nvidia and its partners have
established. But what we have seen time
and time again is China build technology
that the world said was outside of its
grasp.
We know that Beijing is pouring
investment into becoming a
self-sufficient
AI state.
Can it succeed? This is a story that
will define the world's future.
>> [music]
>> Mhm.